baited how to end the
israeli-palestinian conflict at Harvard
University's Institute of Politics this
is an hour-and-a-half one of the
missions of this school is to Train
public leaders to think hard about
critical issues of the day
certainly this evening we are going to
be addressing confronting and thinking
hard about some of those issues as they
relate to Israel and Palestine tonight
our critical issue is to bring it to
point is Israel and Palestine after
disengagement where do we go from here
as we know both parties Israelis and
Palestinians are shortly headed toward
elections in January for the
Palestinians probably in late March for
the Israelis since the disengagement in
August both sides are wrestling mightily
with their internal constituents some on
board for peace some reluctant some not
so anxious at all to proceed with what
is still an unknown in uncertain future
but there is a ray of hope if you've
read the papers in the past couple days
an israeli-palestinian peace soccer team
a joint team has showed up in Spain
what's interesting about this is that
beneath the rhetoric beneath the
politics there is a level of humanity in
both suffering and hope that these two
peoples will soon join hands and produce
a better and a different path and
tonight I think we're here to discuss
what that path might look like what I
want to do before introducing our two
speakers is to make clear what our forum
is for this discussion first each
speaker will make a 10-minute opening
statement on the topic then for
approximately 45 minutes or so I will
moderate a question-and-answer session
from you the audience we will conclude
with two minute closing statements from
each speaker and while I encourage you
to ask any question you deem appropriate
to professors Chomsky and Dershowitz and
I include in that tough questions I also
ask for the sake of the audience that
you be brief and respect the right of
each speaker to respond as well
please remember that civility is the
cornerstone of our democracy and
certainly a hallmark here at the forum
born in Brooklyn Professor Alan
Dershowitz graduated from Brooklyn
College and Yale Law School at Yale he
graduated first in his class and served
as editor-in-chief of the Yale Law
Review
after clerking for Chief Judge David
Roslin and justice Arthur Goldberg he
was appointed to the Harvard Law faculty
at age 25 there wasn't even time for you
to join a mid-career program here at the
school and he became a full professor at
28 the youngest in the school's history
when not teaching students he found time
to be one of the country's most
accomplished defense lawyers and
authored over 20 books his latest the
case for peace how the arab-israeli
conflict can be solved has received
favorable reviews from former President
Bill Clinton and Middle East negotiator
Dennis Ross at Harvard Law School where
he has the Felix Frankfurter professor
of law professor Dershowitz teaches
courses in criminal law constitutional
litigation civil liberties and violence
legal ethics and human rights professor
Noam Chomsky son of a Hebrew scholar
professor Chomsky was born in
Philadelphia while he acquired his PhD
from the University of Pennsylvania in
1955
much of his research leading to his
degree was done here at Harvard between
1951 and 1955 in 1955 he joined MIT and
in 61 was appointed full professor in
the department of modern languages and
linguistics from his articulate
opposition to the Vietnam War in the
mid-60s to his book manufacturing
consent in 1988 and to his even more
challenging text 9/11 published after
the terrorist attack that year Noam
Chomsky has never retreated from taking
on the most pressing issues of our day
professor Chomsky is the Institute
professor of linguistics at MIT and
teaches classes in linguistic Theory
syntax semantics and the philosophy of
language before we begin and to set the
appropriate tone in context for this
evening I'd like us to have a brief look
at a short clip from a forum event last
year
hi my name is Laura dagi I am a junior
in the college and I was wondering as a
leader who is internationally recognized
in the struggle for peace what advice do
you have for the rising leaders of our
generation also hold on people don't be
like us be different you know thousand
and a very little patience for history I
believe that to imagine is more
important than to remember let me just
repeat that so that we have that as the
tone and the context for our discussion
tonight and I quote from Shimon Peres
first of all don't be like us be
different
personally I have very little patience
for history I believe that to imagine is
more important to remember so tonight
let us imagine what should be the next
steps in the process of achieving peace
in the Middle East
for your knowledge a coin toss conducted
by the Harvard speech in parliamentary
debate Society has determined that
professor Dershowitz will speak first
for 10 minutes after that we will go to
directly to professor Chomsky and then
the floor will be open professor
Dershowitz thank you it's a great honor
for me to be participating in a debate
with a man who has been called the
world's top public intellectual my
connections to Noam Chomsky go back a
long time in the 1940s I was a camper
and he a counselor in a Hebrew speaking
Zionist camp in the Pocono Mountains
called camp Mossad in the 1960s we both
worked against the Vietnam War in the
1970s we had the first of our many
debates about the arab-israeli conflict
I advocated ending the Israeli
occupation in exchange for peace and
recognition of Israel he advocated a
one-state solution modeled on Lebanon
and Yugoslavia we debated again in the
1980s in the 1990s I have the text I
hope that our once a decade encounter
will continue for many decades to come
though I doubt we will agree with each
other the debate today occurs at a time
of real potential for peace Shimon Peres
Israel's elder statesman in the peace
camp today quit the Labour Party and
announced his support for Ariel Sharon
in the upcoming election quote in my
eyes it is not a problem of parties but
a problem of peace how to create a
strong Coalition for peace the elements
are now in place for a real peace as I
wrote in the case for peace when the
Palestinian leadership wants a
Palestinian state more than it wants to
see the destruction of Israel that will
finally be a two-state solution the
untimely death of Yasser Arafat makes
the two-state solution a real
possibility I call our Fox death
untimely because if it had occurred five
years earlier we might now be
celebrating the anniversary
of Palestinian statehood ourfox decision
to turn down the Clinton Barack plan for
Palestinian statehood was characterized
by Prince Bandar of Saudi Arabia as
quote a crime against the Palestinians
in fact against the entire region the
crime and the death that it needlessly
caused can never be undone but this is a
time to move forward and to assure that
the crime is not repeated the time has
come for compromise my friend Amos oz
the great novelist and leader of the
Israeli peace movement has said there
are two possible resolutions to a
conflict of this kind the Shakespearean
and the Chekhovian
and a Shakespeare drama every right is
wrong every act is revenged every
injustice is made right and perfect
justice is prevail prevails but at the
end of the play everybody lies dead on
the stage in a Chekhov play everybody's
disillusioned embittered heartbroken are
disappointed but they remain alive we
need to check off the resolution to the
arab-israeli tragedy this will require
the elevation of pragmatism over
ideology it will require that both sides
give up rights rights giving up rights
is a hard thing to do it will require
that each side recognizes and
acknowledges the pain and the suffering
of the other and it will require an end
to the hateful attitudes and speech that
some on each side direct against the
other sometimes it's better to start at
the end the ultimate solution is not as
much in dispute these days as is the
means for getting there
I believe that even professor Chomsky
and I have the same basic agreement
about a number of very important
elements of what a pragmatic resolution
might look like professor Chomsky now
acknowledges that the two-state solution
may be quote the best of the rotten
ideas around I'll settle for that he
also seems to acknowledge that those who
advocate the so-called Palestinian right
of return or pandering to their people
and misleading them into believing
that the arisia another weapon a
demographic weapon that can destroy
Israel I think we both agree that
Jerusalem should be divided essentially
along demographic lines with the
Palestinians controlling the Palestinian
population and Israel controlling the
Jewish population that the borders
between Israel and the Palestinian state
should be based roughly on the UN
resolution 242 that Israel properly
ended its occupation of the Gaza and
that it should end its occupation of all
Palestinian cities and population
centers on the West Bank that terrorism
must stop and that the Palestinian state
that results from this piece must be as
contiguous as possible and economically
and politically viable they remained
considerable differences between us and
more importantly between the Israeli
government and the Palestinian Authority
that must resolve these issues and
actually sit down and make peace some of
these differences are attitudinal I
believe that peace is a realistic
possibility where as professor Chomsky
apparently believes there is no chance
for peace at least as reflected by the
German title of his new book Kiner
Schantz fear Friedman which translates
as no chance for peace why a Palestinian
state is not possible to be established
with Israel and the United States I hope
you're wrong
the differences are quite specific
relating to precise boundaries and
considerations that are quite important
the devil always being in the details I
strongly believe however that there is a
genuine will for peace on both sides now
and that the pragmatic differences can
and will be resolved and here I think
the Academy can play a very important
and positive role in fostering peace at
the moment I'm sad to report that many
academics around the world are
contributing to an atmosphere that makes
peace more difficult to achieve they are
encouraging those Palestinians who see
the end of Israel as their ultimate goal
to persist in their ideological and
terrorist campaign by demonizing and D
legitimating Israel
the international community and on
university campuses throughout the world
they send a doubly destructive message
to those who must make peace on the
ground to the Palestinians the messages
don't compromise if you hold out long
enough the next generation of leaders
will buy into your efforts the dealer
Jetta mate Israel and will give you the
total victory you seek to the Israelis
the message is whatever you do in the
name of compromise you will continue to
be attacked demonized vested from
boycotted and D legitimated so why make
the compromise efforts as I travel
around college campuses in the United
States I noticed a stark difference many
of those who support the Palestinian
cause tend to be very opposed to Israel
comparing the Jewish state to Nazism and
apartheid comparing Shimon Peres to
Hitler and IDI men calling Israel the
world's worst human rights violators and
suggesting that Israel should be
flattered by a comparison with the
Gestapo these are all quotes the men
Hitler quote from professor Chomsky the
comparison with Gestapo from Norman
Finkelstein whereas most of those on the
Israeli side tend to be supportive of a
peaceful Palestinian state put another
way Pro Palestinians tend to be anti
Israel whereas pro Israelis are often
pro palestinian as well it was not the
Israelis who scuttled the United Nations
two-state solution in 1948 and
themselves originally occupied Gaza and
the West Bank with little or no
objection from the international
community that was Egypt in Jordan it
was not the Israelis who turned down
resolution 242 in 1967 with the famous
three knows no negotiation no peace and
no recognition as Abba Eban put it this
is the first time in history that the
side who won the war sued for peace in
the side that lost the war demanded
unconditional surrender it was not
Israel that turned down the generous
offer at Camp David in Taba the
Palestinian leadership has never missed
an opportunity to miss an opportunity
but it is not too late for peace now I
wish to end my opening remarks today by
making a specific proposal directed to
my distinguished opponent I propose here
today
a peace treaty among academics who
purport to favor peace between Israel
and the Palestinians
I believe that by agreeing to this peace
treaty and by implementing it academics
can actually contribute to encouraging a
pragmatic peace I call today for those
who have supported the Palestinian cause
to stop demonizing Israel to stop dealer
Jetta mating Israel to stop defaming
Israel to stop applying a double
standard to Israel to stop divestiture
and boycotts of Israel and most
importantly to stop being more
Palestinian than the Palestinians
themselves I call on academics who
support Israel not to call for a greater
Israel nor to call for a continuation of
the occupation of Palestinian cities to
stop being more Israeli than the
Israelis themselves and to join the vast
majority of Israeli and American
supporters of Israel who favor the
two-state solution if the two elder
statesmen of Israel Sharon and Peres can
place pragmatism before ideology in
peace before party and come together
toward the center in the interest of a
pragmatic peace then surely two elder
statesmen of the American academic
debate over Israel who share this
platform tonight can also make our
contribution to the peace process by
encouraging those who respect us and
sometimes follow our guidance to move
closer to the center and closer to
accepting a pragmatic non-ideological
resolution of this bitter conflict
ecclesiastes many years ago said to
everything there is a season a time to
throw stones a time to gather stones a
time for war and a time for peace this
is the season of peace let us not let it
pass us by thank you very much
Thank You professor Durst which
professor Chomsky mr. Mendell will
confirm there was an explicit condition
for this debate that is that neither
participant tried to evade the issue by
deceitful allegations about the other so
I therefore congratulate mr. Dershowitz
on having made a true statement I was a
counselor at my side about the rest
there happens to be an ample record in
print or if you like you can ask a
question but I'll keep to the topic and
the rules
the topic is where do we go from here
the answer to that is largely up to us
evidently it requires some understanding
of how we got here the question of where
we're going now has a clear answer it's
given accurately by the leading academic
specialist on the occupation Harvard's
Sarah Roy as she writes that under the
terms of disengagement gazans are
virtually sealed within the strip while
West bankers their lands dismembered by
relentless Israeli settlement will
continue to be penned into fragmented
geographic spaces isolated behind them
between walls and barriers her judgment
is affirmed by Israel's leading
specialists on the West Bank Mayer on
Anthony ste who writes that the
separation wall snaking through the West
Bank will create three Bantu stands his
words North Central and South all
virtually separated from East Jerusalem
the center of Palestinian commercial
cultural and political life and he adds
that this is what he calls the soft
transfer from Jerusalem that is an
unavoidable result of the separation
wall might achieve its goal quoting
still the goal of disintegration of the
Palestinian community after many earlier
10
have failed the human disaster being
planned he continues will turn hundreds
of thousands of people into a sullen
community hostile and nurturing a desire
for revenge it's another example of the
sacrifice of security to expansion
that's been going on for a long time a
European Union report concludes that us
back Israeli programs will virtually end
the prospects for a viable Palestinian
state by the canonization and by
breaking the organic links between East
Jerusalem and the West Bank human rights
watch in a recent statement concurs
there was no effort to conceal the fact
that Gaza disengagement was in reality
West Bank expansion the official plan
for disengagement stated that Israel
will permanently take over major
population centers cities towns and
villages security areas and other places
of special interest to Israel in the
West Bank that was endorsed by the US
ambassador as it had been by the
president
breaking sharply with US policy along
with the disengagement plan Israel
announced investment of tens of millions
of dollars in West Bank settlements
Prime Minister Sharon immediately
approved new housing units in the town
of allowed to mean to the east of
Jerusalem the core of the salient that
divides the southern from the central
Bathurst and to use benveniste Sturm and
also announced other expansion plans
there is near unanimity that all of this
violates international law the consensus
was expressed by US judge Bergen Thal in
his separate declaration attached to the
world court judgment ruling that the
separation wall is illegal in Bergen
tells words the Fourth Geneva Convention
and international human rights law are
applicable to the
Palestinian territory and must therefore
be fully complied with by Israel
accordingly the segments of the wall
being built by Israel to protect the
settlements are if so facto in violation
of international humanitarian law which
happens to mean about 80 percent of the
wall
two months later Israel's High Court
rejected that judgement ruling that the
separation wall in quoting must take
into account the need to provide
security for Israelis living in the West
Bank including their property rights
this is consistent with chief justice
Barack's doctrine that Israeli law
supersedes international law
particularly in East Jerusalem annexed
in violation of Security Council orders
and practically speaking he's correct
as long as the United States continues
to provide the required economic
military and diplomatic support as it
has been doing for thirty years in
violation of the international consensus
on a third state settlement you can find
detailed documentation about all of this
in work of mine and others who have
supported the international consensus
for 30 years in print explicitly in
Israeli literature like Bennie Morris's
histories you can find ample evidence
about the nature of the occupation in
Morris's words founded on brute force
repression and fear collaboration and
treachery beatings and torture chambers
and daily intimidation humiliation and
manipulation along with stealing of
valuable land and resources like other
Israeli political and legal commentators
Morris Reserve special criticism for the
Supreme Court whose record he writes
will surely go down as a dark day in the
annals of Israel's judicial system
keeping to the diplomatic record the
first time both sides of course rejected
242 the first important step forward was
in 1971 when President Sadat of Egypt
offered a full peace treaty to Israel in
return for Israeli withdrawal from the
occupied territories that would have
ended the international conflict Israel
rejected the offer
choosing expansion over security in this
case expansion into the Egyptian Sinai
where general Sharon's forces had driven
thousands of farmers into the desert to
clear the land for the old jewish city
of young eight the us-backed israel
stand those decisions led to the 1973
war and the earth disaster for israel
the US and Israel then recognized that
Egypt could not be dismissed and finally
accepted that's 1971 offer at Camp David
in 1979 but by then the agreement
included the demand for a Palestinian
state which had reached the
international agenda in 1976 the major
Arab states introduced a resolution to
the UN Security Council calling for a
peace settlement on the international
border based on UN 242 but now adding a
Palestinian state in the occupied
territories that Syria Egypt Jordan and
every other relevant state the u.s.
vetoed the resolution again in 1980 the
General Assembly passed similar
resolutions year after year with the
United States and Israel opposed the
matter reached a head in 1988 when the
PLO moved from tacit approval to formal
acceptance of the two-state consensus
Israel responded with the declaration
that there can be no as they put it
additional Palestinian state between
Jordan and the C Jordan already being a
Palestinian state that Shimon Peres
section here and also that the status of
the territories must be settled
according to Israeli guidelines the u.s.
endorsed Israel
and I can only add what I wrote at the
time it's as if someone were to argue
that Jews don't need a second homeland
in Israel because they already have New
York in May 1997 for the first time
Paris's Labor Party agreed not to rule
out the establishment of a Palestinian
state with limited sovereignty in areas
excluding major Jewish settlement blocs
that is the three Canton's that were
being constructed with us support the
highest rate of post Oslo settlement was
in 2000 the final year of Clinton's term
and Prime Minister of Iraq's maps of the
u.s. Israel proposals at Camp David
Shoah salient east of Jerusalem
bisecting the West Bank and a northern
said in virtually dividing the northern
from the central canta and I have the
maps if you want them the current map
considerably extends these aliens and
the isolation of East Jerusalem accrue
the my maps are from the leading Israeli
scholars the director of the center the
crucial issue at Camp David was
territorial not the refugee issue for
which artha agreed to a pragmatic
solution as food back the leading
scholar reveals no Palestinian could
accept the canonization including the
u.s. favourite Mahmoud Abbas a Clinton
we also debated because Clinton
recognized that Palestinian objections
had validity and in December 2000
proposed his parameters which went some
way towards satisfying Palestinian
rights in Clinton's words Barack and
Arafat Arafat had both accepted these
parameters as the basis for further
efforts both have expressed some
reservations the reservations were
addressed at a high-level meeting in
Taba which made considerable progress
and might have led to a settlement but
Israel called them off that one week
is the only break in 30 years of us
Israeli rejection ISM high-level
informal negotiations continued leading
to the Geneva Accord of December 2002
welcomed by virtually the entire world
rejected by Israel dismissed by
Washington that could have been the
basis for a just peace it still can
bye-bye then however Bush shall run
bulldozers were demolishing any basis
for it every sane Israeli Hawk
understood that it was absurd for Israel
to leave 8,000 settlers in Gaza
protected by a large part of the army
while taking over scarce water resources
and arable land the same conclusion was
to withdraw from Gaza while expanding
through the West Bank and that will
continue as long as Washington insists
on marching on the road to catastrophe
by rejecting minimal Palestinian rights
I'm quoting the warning of the four
former heads of Israel Shin Beit
Security Service there are clear
alternatives and if that March the
catastrophe continues we will have only
ourselves to blame thank you
in the spirit of discussion of this
forum we are now going to open the floor
to your questions so there are four
microphones one here one got it there
one here in the intermediate stage and
one on the floor directly in front of me
we're going to proceed as follows and so
I want you to listen carefully to
respect this ability of the discourse
that I intend to make sure that we
follow here I'm going to ask you to
introduce yourself and to ask just one
question as the Dean of our school
always reminds people questions end with
a question mark and out of respect for
all of our colleagues and students here
this evening waiting patiently at the
mics I will insist on only one brief
question I would also ask that you wear
appropriate direct your question to one
of the panelists after that panelist
response I will invite his colleague for
a brief comment and then we will return
to the floor so that you know what's
coming I will begin over here go up
across and then back down hi my name is
Nikki Harmon I'm from Jerusalem and this
is a question for pesky professor
Chomsky I wanted to know if you think
that it actually is relevant to dwell
upon forming a shared narrative of both
sides in in going forth towards any any
solution of peace between us is it
important for us to actually agree what
what what forty-eight represents for one
one side and what 48 represents for the
other in order to live together in peace
in the future
yes I think it's very relevant to
understand history if you want to
understand the present yeah I think the
history has to be objectively verifiable
and it doesn't become true because
professor Chomsky says it's true there
was a two-state solution proposed by the
United Nations in 1948 and if the
Palestinians had accepted what the
Israelis accepted a small non contiguous
state with Banta stands to quote
professor Chomsky and instead of not
invaded and if the Egyptians had not
occupied the Gaza something that nobody
complained about it was literally a
prison for 20 years and if they're
Jordanians hadn't occupied the West Bank
literally a prison for twenty years and
had the situation gone forward as it was
supposed to go forward in 48 we would
not be here we'd have a two-state
solution but what happened is it's clear
that the Palestinian Arab leadership was
more interested in destroying the
nascent Jewish state of Israel than in
establishing a Palestinian state that is
simply the truth and there is no way to
deny that and no amount of rhetoric can
undercut that reality because well let
me bring responsibly concussed I was
whoa well I participated in the drafting
in a small way of 242 I was off the
Goldbergs assistant at the Supreme Court
he drafted two for two he conferred with
me and consulted with me
two for two clearly contemplated Israel
retaining some of the territories needed
to create secure boundaries in 1967 the
UN rejected a formulation of Israel
returning all the territories or the
territories and kept only territories
and as the result of that Israel
accepted two for two and at Khartoum all
the Arab states and the Palestinians
unanimously rejected two for two and
issued their three knows no which no
compromises no wreck
ignition no peace if we can do the truth
of the matter is if we can cover the
friendly foreign relations their United
States approached the Jordanians and the
others and agree that got them to agree
to accept qualified acceptance of two
for two on the condition that there
would be minor and mutual adjustments
with no substantial change to the mat
okay
there were curved lines all right what
you can't see behind the podium is that
both of my colleagues are armed with
several dozen maps and that could get
that could that could get dangerous in
this part of the conversation so I'm
gonna ask for some restraint so we make
sure that we go directly to our
participants yes sir thank you Ken
sweeter I'd like to bring it to the
present and I'd like to ask professor
Dershowitz since this was a major point
made by Professor Chomsky whether or not
you believe Israel is ready to negotiate
for a contiguous state not one of three
separate Bantu stance yes
now contiguous depends of course on
whether it means contiguous with in the
West Bank or contiguous including a
connection between the West Bank and the
Gaza now it was the UN that created the
lack of continuity between the Gaza
Strip and the West Bank in fact the
original proposals for Israel required
complete non continuity the north was
separated from Tel Aviv Tel Aviv from
Jerusalem yet Israel accepted a non
contiguous state under the Clinton
parameters there would be complete
continuity with a circumferential
highway around Jerusalem much like route
128 it would take nine extra minutes to
get from Ramallah to Bethlehem then in
the middle of the night through
Jerusalem because the shortest distance
between two lines taken into account
traffic is not a straight line now there
are all kinds of creative proposals for
functional contiguity
between the West Bank and Gaza including
a high-tech rail line recently designed
by the ran foul nation I have a picture
of that in in my book it
also looks much like the Danish railroad
a high-tech waterway all kinds of ways
of connecting all the Palestinian States
do we cities to each other under this
proposal no point in Palestine would be
more than 90 minutes away from any other
point in Palestine including Gaza it
would take 34 minutes to get from Hebron
to Gaza City on the rail line that is
functional contiguity and the fact that
the leader of the Labour Party for years
has quit his party to join a new party
and the leader of lis could has quit his
party both in the interest of making
peace persuades me plus an hour I had a
loan in Israel not so long ago with
Prime Minister Sharon and much time that
I've spent with the former prime
minister Perez that the will toward
peace is absolute in genuine having said
that I also believe the will to peace by
Abbas and many of the leaders of the
Palestinian Authority is genuine - thank
God Israel has to make peace with the
Palestinians and not with the
professor's comment from 23 from their
sake human rights watch in the European
Union but there's a very simple test
that we could try let's if those are
that's a valid approach to contiguity
for the Palestinian state in 22 percent
of the former Palestine let's propose it
for the Israeli state 178 percent of the
former Palestine let's ask who would
dream of proposing that it was proposed
the peel Commission proposed we're
talking about today thousands of people
have been killed by terrorism you don't
expect a country to go back to a
proposal that was offered and rejected
many many years earlier options change
when rejection ISM sets in okay let's go
to our next question
my name is you mentioned the connection
between Gaza and West Bank right but I
think what about the pieces of West Bank
we're going to end up with elements are
continuing to be built inside the West
Bank the wall is being built inside the
borders of 1967 so now please talk to me
about peace about Pro Palestine when it
comes to building walls and actually
separating the West Bank from East
Jerusalem okay
here's what a Palestinian state would
have looked like had Camp David and Taba
been accepted it would be a completely
contiguous West Bank with an area that
including male adumim and some of the
other areas rights out of Jerusalem
which would become part of Israel and
would remain within the wall the
ultimate goal is to have a separation
fence that is on the border the accepted
border and I'll tell you what I think
the real options are today the real
options are if this new peace party wins
if the Sharan Paris peace party wins it
will offer the Palestinians a very good
deal a deal much like that what was
rejected at Camp David and Taba and by
the way if you think it was the Israelis
who rejected it just ask Bill Clinton he
has told me Dennis Ross has told me it
was completely in the fall completely in
the hands of the Arafat and that's true
of Prince Bandar as well but if it gets
accepted this time there and if the
peace party prevails again they will be
offered something very very close to
that it will be a viable Palestinian
state much more viable than anything
Israel was offered and accepted in 38
and in 47 and I think every reasonable
person today would urge the Palestinians
not to repeat the disastrous mistakes
they made in 48 they made in 67 they
made in 2000 they made in 2001 this time
say yes accept a Palestinian state build
it create an economy create a political
system and finally peace can be
Thank You professor Chava those who you
would like to see the map I have it it
says I said from wrong boondock the
leading Israeli scholar the head of the
Shimon Peres Peace Center it shows this
is the Camp David map which was which
Clinton recognized was impossible which
is why they went on to Taba and it cuts
through the West Bank completely yes
Dennis Ross was the US negotiators where
it is meaningless
I'll be happy to say it it's obvious to
any reader it stops you know right
obvious to you it stops notice that his
book stops immediately before Taba
why because Clinton's parameters and
what Clinton said about the acceptance
of them by both sides and the table
negotiations completely undermines
Dennis Ross's book so he therefore
terminates it right before that and can
therefore make these absurd claims but
if you want to learn something about it
look at Israeli scholarship it's much
more serious thank you good evening I
like to thank both professors for
speaking so eloquently tonight my name
is Josh Coates I'm a recent alum of
Harvard College and I'm really glad to
be back I have sort of a simple question
for a professor Chomsky it seems to me
that you left out in your analysis the
element of violence psychological
physical against Israel against Jews and
it seems to me also that the history
that Professor dish was described a lot
of that is dictated by what what
happened the terrorism the wars against
Jews especially considering the
immediate history right before the
establishment of the State of Israel the
Holocaust and everything that has
happened since so I'd like you to
address the effect of the psychological
effect in the physical effect of war and
terrorism on Israel
it's a half of a very important question
the other half of it is what's the
effect of war on terrorism on the
Palestinians now if you take a look at
what we are not supposed to talk about
that question here but if you look at
them both you'll find that what any Mars
described is in fact correct the balance
of terror and violence is overwhelmingly
against the Palestinians not
surprisingly given the balance of forces
and that's even true that's true right
to the president I mean for you know for
decades Israel was able to run the West
Bank virtually with no forces as Laura's
point others point out because the
population was so passive while they
were being humiliated beaten tortured
land stolen and so on just as I quoted
finally there was a reaction and it's
interesting to see the US reaction to it
in the first month of the Intifada this
one October 2000 in the first month of
the Intifada at 275 Palestine 74
Palestinians were killed for Israelis
were killed so on the occupied
territories the Israeli army according
to its own records fired a million
bullets in the first day which disgusted
the generals when they learned about it
Israel first few days of the Intifada
was using us helicopters they don't make
them us helicopters to attack civilian
complexes apartment houses and so on
killing and wounding dozens of people
and the u.s. did respond to that Clinton
responded by sending the biggest
shipment of military helicopters in a
decade to Israel the press responded to
by not publishing it I should add
refusing to publish it because it was
repeatedly brought to their attention
well while the ratio was 20 to 1 which
is pretty much what it's been for a long
time there was no concern here then over
the next 2-3 years the ratio reduced to
closer to 3 to 1 and then came enormous
concern about the one not three and this
goes back for a long time what I quoted
from Mara's is
you know I don't know follow the very
brief response the idea that there is
this vast conspiracy between the
American media and both Democrats like
Clinton and Republicans like Bush to
hide the truth from the American public
just does not bear reality Israel is an
open society any newspaper can come and
cover it why would not the newspapers
cover these stories before one reason
they are figments of Chomsky's
imagination well then and there just
never happened now I want to talk about
another figment of his imagination
constantly quotes constantly quotes many
Morris as if many Morris supports his
position what happened is many Morris
was asked whether or not I accurately
quote him in my book the case for peace
and Benny Morris responded as follows he
still holds the views that I attributed
to him that I am right about his views
and that someone could read Morris's
books this is a quote from Morris and
arrived at exactly the same conclusions
and yet professor Chomsky by selectively
quoting and by picking tidbits out of
context knowing that you're not going to
check up on him tells you essentially
that what you believe in the American
media whether it be the Washington Post
The Boston Globe or the New York Times
is not true in order to get the true
meaning of the world you have to move to
Planet Chomsky where the news reflects
his perspective on reality
well I urge you to move to the real
world read the real news don't read the
Selective Israeli journalist that he
talks about listen to Dennis Ross Dennis
Ross actually helped to draw the maps he
was there when I haven't done my two
minutes when he said when I asked Dennis
Ross allotted a minute
about these maps and what what
apparently Chomsky would say in response
Ross said ask professor Chomsky one
thing were you there Dennis Ross was
there
he knows what maps were presented to the
Palestinians and what they rejected
thank you the head of the show
Center doesn't right we know her right
before he's refuted the way Venice
rusted presents he was involved in
negotiation since before Oslo right
through Camp David up to the present a
long historical account of it you can
read it if you can read Hebrew or some
of it's in English the one all this
smoke that was blown had to do with one
fact that I mentioned one and you can
check it and please do in the earth in
the first month of the Intifada I'm now
using Israeli sources seventy four
Palestinians were killed for Jews in the
occupied territories the first few days
this is reported in the press here
Boston Globe Israel was using us
helicopters to attack apartment
complexes Clinton reacted with the
biggest deal in a decade check it out
it's in the public record not if not
questioned by anyone to send military
helicopters to Israel the there has been
a database search of the US it was
reported in Europe it was reported by
Amnesty International it's reported in
jane's defence weekly the main military
magazine in the world
there was a database search for the u.s.
press and they found nothing I know of
explicit cases and I'll be glad to tell
them to you where the press was
approached and asked just a report the
fact why Chomsky why didn't they report
it are they bad reporters what's their
motive explain why because times where
the post
wouldn't report this great story from
Planet Chomsky gentlemen weekly from the
international press and so on yeah they
wouldn't you have to given that the JFK
forum is here for the purpose of
creating educated citizens and
participants in a very important debate
I would ask each of you to exercise a
bit of restraint so that we can have
more of our questions from the audience
please stand identify yourself Nancy
Murray and if you want the answer why
didn't they report a CPC propaganda and
the promised land now my question
getting back to today and your
functional continuity contiguity
contiguity I would like to know have you
seen not just the wall but the eight
terminals that are being built under
your vision under your compromise will
the terminals be dismantled will the
wall be dismantled will Jerusalem East
Jerusalem be under the sovereignty of
Palestinians not just under the control
and will the Palestinians have their
water resources back will they have
freedom of movement I mean is this the
kind of vision you have is it a genuine
one or are you talking about
Sharon's plan well I can work it was
so-called Helen I can only tell you what
my proposal is and I think it's a
proposal it's today widely supported
within Israel that is that the ultimate
security fence I've been through not
only the terminals but the most recent
terminal the most recent high-tech
terminal that was just built I proposed
actually that the security fence be
placed on wheels and constantly be able
to be moved consistent with Israeli
security needs the Israeli Supreme Court
the Israeli Supreme Court ruled last
year and Chomsky misstated it no Israeli
justice has ever said and I challenge
you to find a statement that Barak has
ever said that Israeli law Trump's
international law that is simply not
true what he said is that Israeli law
enforces international law but
international law is not determined by a
body in the International Court of
Justice which excludes Israelis from
serving on it and which will not allow
an Israeli ever to be a member of that
Court it would be as if Southern black
in the 1930s accepted as the correct
statement of American constitutional law
a decision by an all-white Court in a
case involving a black and a white man
no
Israel accepts international law
enforces international law and the goal
of course of my peace proposal is that
the security fence will eventually be
dismantled when terrorism ends but
before that it would be on the border
the way the Gaza fence is now on the
border and that water rights would be
respected there would be complete and
total freedom of movement within the
contiguous West Bank and between the
West Bank and Gaza
even today Israel has given up control
over the Rafah crossing it now has a
video which you can watch to see as
Palestinians monitor exit and entry
through the Rafa a gateway that's going
to be the future and if there is a will
to peace if there is a desire to make
sure that there are two States not
simply once day a Palestinian state then
all of these issues can be resolved and
will be resolved Israel has shown the
will to resolve these issues certainly I
support a resolution that gives dignity
gives economic viability gives political
freedom and freedom of movement to the
Palestinian people's yes once again I
purposely quoted justice Bergen to all
because I know of mr. Gershowitz his
opposition to the World Court I
therefore cut coach quoted the US
justice not the World Court who stated
that the segments of the wall being
built to protect the settlements or if
so facto in violation of international
humanitarian law that's 80% of the wall
two months later Israel's High Court
stated in contrast that the separation
wall must take into account the need to
provide security for Israelis living in
the West Bank including their property
rights that's in direct contradiction to
justice Bergen Saul's
separate declaration unanimously by the
World Court that's right and if you
would like his comment about how
international law you Israeli law
supersedes international law in East
Jerusalem because now those next to
Israel illegally I'll be happy to
provide it to you just any name but
that's not what you said please let's go
to the
I'm a second year student at the law
school professor Chomsky it seems like
you've done a lot of remembering and
very little imagining and Alan
Dershowitz his idea is if they seem
funny to have a train or you know some
type of other high-tech connection at
least they're creative and at least
they're moving us forward how do you
deal with the issues of refugees how
would you connect Gaza and the West Bank
or is the only solution in your mind a
one-state solution what would you do
about Jerusalem well as you would know
if you looked at anything I'd written
instead of if you would know if you look
at anything that's written I've been
supporting a two-state settlement since
the early 1970s and in print and perhaps
you can show me some of mr. mr.
Dershowitz ooze material in print
supporting it I haven't found it but yes
that's my position since the early 70s
all in print as for connections the
issue recall at Camp David and at Taba
and today is territorial in the West
Bank okay
if the and the current proposals are
exactly as I described go through the
sources I mentioned or find any other
ones that you think are serious those
are the major Israeli and Western
academic sources and human rights
organizations and so on yes they break
up the West Bank into three Fanta stands
as benveniste said with virtually no
organic connection to East Jerusalem
which is the center of Palestinian life
that's why the EU and you're in the
European Union and Human Rights Watch
and others flatly reject them now it is
possible what Israel is in fact doing
now is developing a huge infrastructure
system in the West Bank with highways
for Israelis and paths for Palestinians
so that they don't have to interact with
one another which means that this
network around the West Bank which will
be annexed to Israel roughly 40 to 50
percent people can travel in it in great
comfort from the suburbs around Tel Aviv
including all the water resources
including
terrible and they can get to Tel Aviv in
Jerusalem or the Palestinians will be
following paths actually I can read to
you if you like how Israeli journalists
are describing that and if you'd like to
check it out for yourself
I suggest some time that you take what's
officially called the Palestinian Road
from Bethlehem to Ramallah which takes
like 10 minutes on the Jewish highway
I've taken it it's a little winding road
the road goes right next to a Wadi if
it's not raining you're lucky if you
don't fall into it and often the hill
you can see the pads where people are
sort of moving on the days when the
settlers are not traveling the roads are
empty because there's no way to get
anywhere I mean you're going up
broken-down taxi cab up to a barrier and
then you transport someone who needs
dialysis a pregnant woman carrying over
a ditch and go to another cab and so on
yeah that's kind of continuity and again
I say the same thing if that's
reasonable then fine let's impose that
kind of continuity on Israel okay
listen to the words there's an element
of racism in one of the phrases we've
heard today in describing this as a
Jewish highway 1.2 million Israelis are
Arabs many of them are Christians there
is no such thing as a Jewish highway in
Israel there are Jewish there are Muslim
highways in Saudi Arabia there are
Muslim only roads in other parts of the
world but there is no road there's
nothing in Israel that is opened only to
Jews even synagogues everything is open
to Israeli Arabs every Road is opened to
an Israeli rare Arab when the peace
solution is finally proposed had the
Camp David and Taba Accords been
accepted the Palestinians would be free
to build any super highways they choose
and indeed Israel has offered now a
super highway in a super roadway between
Gaza and Jerusalem picked up straight
between Gaza and Heffron
and the idea of it's very difficult I
acknowledge how to connect East
Jerusalem to Bethlehem to Ramallah and
to Jericho will require a challenge but
people are working on it there are
creative solutions being proposed
I am waiting along with the student who
asked the question for some creative
positive imaginary imaginative solutions
from Professor Chomsky all we're hearing
it's a recitation of the past evil
American Empire and Israel are involved
I congratulate mr. dersh which again for
one true statement they are not Jewish
their Israeli roads that is they are
roads of the sovereign's
when I'm quoting the High Court the
sovereign state of the Jewish people in
Israel and the Diaspora oh that's like
saying that British roads are roads of
the sovereign Anglican people on Israeli
roads there are Israeli highways and
Palestinian pads if you want a creative
solution I mentioned one let's go to I
mentioned there's any the court the Taba
agreements which is real cancelled is
separate you are yes hi my name is
Abraham Riesman I'm it's sort of funny
and it's long been one of the sort of
strange paradoxes in world politics that
Americans and people the world over can
get so enraged about either side when
it's a conflict that many of us will
never first-hand experience specifically
how you like to see young people
me and us here envisioning the conflict
in the future because a lot of us have a
tendency to internalize it to a degree
where it's not about people anymore on
both sides there are people I know who
are ardent Zionists who never go to
Israel who believe in it because they're
very religiously Jewish and all of a
sudden it becomes attached from the
realities on the ground and there are
people who are very Pro Palestinian who
are strongly in favor of social justice
and economic joke a thank you yeah how
do you professor Chomsky well I my
feeling is you should you should
approach as an American and for them as
for an American it is one of the lead
issues in the world you know Israel is
able to do these things to dismantle and
destroy the West Bank to disintegrate
the community because of the United
States gives it massive aid unparalleled
in international affairs not only
military and economic but also
diplomatic by as I mentioned for the
last 30 years unilaterally blocking the
two-state settlement which Israel also
totally rejected alone the two of them
and as long as you the American taxpayer
goes on supporting this yes it will
continue and it'll lead to exactly what
the Baptist and style solution that
benveniste and others describe right on
the ground and yes so therefore it's
enough of enormous importance to
Americans as for solutions pretty
straightforward there they were coming
close to a solution at Taba until Israel
called it off if negotiations continued
leading to several proposals of which
the most detailed were the Geneva
Accords you can find out what I thought
about all of those in print you can ask
mr. Dershowitz where he supported them
in print the Geneva Accords in December
2002 were accepted by essentially the
whole world Israel rejected them the
u.s. refused even to send a message to
the Jiva meetings but they're still
potentially alive and American citizens
can compel our own government to reverse
its program to accept the international
consent
for the first time and then we'll be on
the way to a solution thank you I too
have written about the Geneva Accords
and in Chapter six of my book and I
generally support many elements of the
Geneva Accords I do not support the
right of return that is the idea that
700,000 or now 4 million Palestinians
can demographically destroy Israel which
is rejected in the Geneva it is of
course it is not accepted or rejected it
is left for future negotiations ok did
not say anything because Finian's had
already at Camp David and acaba accepted
the so-called pragmatic settlement which
would not affect the demographic
character
if you want to learn about the serious
scholarship like simply I can tell you
that President Clinton told me directly
and personally that what caused the
failure of the can't David Taub Accords
was the refusal of the Palestinians and
our thoughts to give up the right of
return that was the sticking point
wasn't Jerusalem it wasn't borders it
was the right of return well you believe
if you believe that the United States
has unilaterally rejected the two-state
solution that's what we heard from
Professor Chomsky that it's the United
States that has rejected the two-state
solution when every modern American
president has favored the two-step
solution I say welcome to Planet Chomsky
exercise you can believe one of two
things the extensive published
diplomatic record which I give you a
sample of and you can find in detail on
books of mine and others or what mr.
Dershowitz says he heard from somebody
no war and check the diplomatic records
check the map sir
your question Andrey Denis Russia's book
which contains appendices which have the
diplomatic record what Chomsky is
telling you to do is read the available
record in Esperanto he constantly tells
you to read sources he knows you can't
read because he knows if you check his
sources they are you don't find it in
the press his answer is it's not in the
press it's part of a conspiracy to keep
it out of the documentary record which
happens to be quite different not only
on this issue but you know gentlemen I
think it's important that we take
advantage of your expertise here many
years have wisdom by hearing a couple
more questions please you are hi my name
is tal silverstein and I was campaign
manager and later on special advisor to
Prime Minister Barak in Camp David so I
think I know where at least my friend
I'm saying it's only because I think you
have a question yes please go directly
to your question
Nik
you know there was a question before
that had about a seven-minute
prerequisite this is it this is an
expert who was there who was an
eyewitness I think he should be
permitted to proceed his question with a
one minute corner
I don't I don't wanna go I don't want to
go into history and I'm a little excited
because you have to understand one thing
I believe we have only now my question
but let's say that the new party after
the election
guided by sean is to offer the
palestinians a deal it doesn't matter
which the a deal that will be accepted
by most Palestinians would you support
this deal even if it doesn't reflect the
views or your well I'm glad to see that
you I assume you endorse from conducts
expert expert knowledge correct I
therefore recommend to all of you who
read English that you read the summary
of his review of all of this in the
Journal of be much longer it's on the
Paris Center website which describes in
detail if you like I can quote it from
you as to what the negotiators in the
background he was one of the negotiators
in the background and he was from he was
from Oslo and his study he was one of
the advisors as you know read you're the
one who called me
you agree with him you think if you
think not tell these shimon peres center
to fire and miss director those are the
basic Israeli documents furthermore
they're supported by plenty of others if
you want to know more about Taba you can
read the European Union report accepted
by both sides which says exactly what I
said as to your question yes I already
told you the answer there is a very good
solution on the table it's the solution
that they came close to in Taba before
Israel cancelled it and that was then
carried forward by high-level Israeli
and Palestinian negotiators informally
leading to the Geneva that's why it's
leading to the December 2002 Geneva
Accords which are right there you can
read them in English you can read them
in Hebrew there on the web no problem
look up the gue Shalom Shalom website
that's a pretty good solution even if it
wasn't the plan that you think is
optimal oh hi what are your opinions
because I know most Israelis probably
would vote for it if most Palestinians
would vote for it even if it's not
documenting it's not going to be optimal
especially if most persons would vote
for it would you accept it you asked
what I thought it what I thought is what
I think is if there's a very simple
creative solution which has me very
close to the international consensus
that I've been supporting for 30 over 30
years and that the United States and
Israel been unilaterally blocking it was
reached by high-level Israeli and
Palestinian negotiators and though there
hasn't been a vote about it my guess is
that if there was a poll on both sides
majorities on both sides would probably
accept it but that's totally different
from the proposals of of the Sheeran
Paris party the Kadima or incidentally
of Paris's Labor Party so far
or he simply endorsed the expansionist
program that breaks up the West Bank
into Canton's perfect perfect selective
use of shimon peres you know the Shimon
Perez Peace Center I want to read you a
quote from Norm Tomsky he described
Shimon Perez he described Ronald Reagan
at one point as the semi-divine Reagan
as one of the iconic group of mass
murderers from Hitler to Idi Amin to
Perez so on the one day of the week you
find Nam Chomsky describing Perez this
great man of peace as an iconic mass
murderer and on another day he's quoting
the authority of Shimon Perez to make
peace I mean where do you stand on
Shimon Perez is he a man of peace or is
he an iconic mass murderer he is a an
iconic mass murderer and I've given
plenty of evidence for it and he is not
a man of peace what I didn't read not
refer to Shimon Peres
I referred to the director of the Shimon
Peres
Peace Center not C Mon Paris Shimon
Peres the man who just joined in to make
peace is an iconic mass murder a woman
not a man of peace they want me to run
through his record 1996 he informed the
press that a Palestinian state will
never happen and in 1997 he said maybe
we can ultimately tolerate it somewhere
but we're not saying we're not thank you
you are my name is any Levin I'm a first
year at the Kennedy School my question
is for professor at gerschwitz you had
said that one of the steps in your plan
for peace in the future was for the
Palestinians to stop their terrorism
expertise so my question would be if you
were advising the Israeli government is
there anything about their current
strategy and how they respond to these
terrorism tactics that you would advise
them to change yes I would I do not
favor
for example house destructions on the
other hand I do think that targeted
killings of ticking bomb terrorists
leaders and terrorists has been quite
effective
hundreds perhaps thousands of terrorist
acts have been prevented including an
attempt to blow up a gas tank outside of
Tel Aviv including an attempt to blow up
a port in our code tens of thousands of
Israelis probably would have been killed
but for the intelligence activities and
the preventive activities of the Israeli
government I have a book coming out in
January called preemption where I set
out all the parameters of where I think
pre-emptive acts are justified where I
think they're not justified I think
Israel gets a C+ or a B - in its
compliance with human rights in fighting
terrorism which is higher than any
country ever has gotten comparably
facing any external threats and I
challenge in fact anybody in this room
or professor Chomsky to name me any
other country which has faced comparable
threats of terrorism comparable external
threats which has ever had a Supreme
Court and an academy which has been more
sensitive to the human rights and civil
rights of those who would destroy it I
say C plus B - if I were an Israeli I
would demand much more I would demand
that it get up to the B+ range but
surely a much better standard than the
United States has followed in Iraq
surely a much higher standard than Egypt
or Jordan surely a much higher standard
than France followed when faced with
terrorist threats and at least
comparable and probably better than
England when it was facing terrorist
threats from Northern Ireland so when
you make comparisons and you argue that
Israel is the worst Human Rights
violator in the world which is the
mantra on planet Chomsky one always has
to look at comparable factors in
comparable countries it's not enough to
single out Israel and say Israel isn't
perfect if in fact you wanted to have
divestiture which Chomsky before he
opposed that favored it if you wanted to
have divestiture I'd favor it if you
listed all the countries in the world in
terms of their compliance with human
rights and did divestiture in order of
their compliance you would never
get to Israel on that less Professor
choice if you would like to here's an
exercise there's an exercise for the
reader I won't waste your time on it
write a letter to Alan Dershowitz ask
him to cite the source where I described
Israel as the worst human rights
violator in the world or even anything
remotely like it if he had ever if he
would ever look at a word that's written
so he would know for example that I was
supporting the two-state settlement in
the early 70s when he was saying nothing
about it and hasn't been told recently
he would also know that I described in
detail how the u.s. Israeli record was
considerably better than the US record
but to answer his challenge there are
certainly cases that are much better
than Israel's record countries that have
suffered far worse terrorism and have
not done anything to take an obvious
case Nicaraguan controversial case
uncontroversial because much as you hate
the World Court the World Court ruled
that the United States was carrying out
what it called unlawful use of force
against Nicaragua that's international
terrorism in lay language the case was
run by one of your distinguished
colleagues the and ordered the u.s. to
stop the terrorist attacks and to pay
massive reparations the u.s. rejected
the court judgment vetoed two Security
Council resolutions supporting the court
judgments went on to practically destroy
the country the number of people killed
in that terrorist attack translating to
per capita equivalents here it would be
about 2.25 million that's more than the
total in all US wars ever there were no
targeted assassinations and unlike
Israel Nicaragua didn't even close
newspapers
I mean Israel has repeatedly closed
newspapers even in Israel but mostly in
the occupied territories because it
claims that they have some connection
with terrorists the leading newspaper in
Nicaragua right to the end was owned by
a supporter of the
terrorist army and I was openly on its
front pages calling for the overthrow of
the government occasionally they reduced
some of its newsprint they never closed
it that's one case an obvious one take
it even more obvious case Cuba the
United States launched Cincinnati Center
I can point out that John F Kennedy
launched a major terrorist attack
against Cuba in 1961 right after the
failure of the Bay of Pigs a very
serious terrorist war plenty of
documentation about it for the best
sources you can you like major terrorist
wars going on right for the present
based in Florida Cuba has not carried
out terrorist actions in the United
States so Cuba has a better human rights
record than Israel Chomsky on the
nowhere else sorry on the issue of
preemption which is the one you raised
yes you raised the challenge about
preemption and I told you there are many
Israel and the United States are both
threatening Iran with destruction well
you know preemption according to
Dershowitz would require that you ran be
carrying out targeted assassinations in
Israel the United States we're gonna go
this is gonna be our last question of
the evening um my name is Laurie
crassula I'm a second year MPP student
thank you for this lively debate what I
have a question kind of directed at both
of you but professor Dirk was near book
you said you hope to have a win-win
situation where everyone had to give
something up and what's clear to me
after this debate and just looking at
history that no one's able to come to a
resolution where they're willing to give
up enough to the other person so it
seems to me that the only way to win is
to have everybody lose so I'd like you
to comment on a proposal where maybe if
you all lost we'd actually come out
winning
well I think there is a win-win possible
situation Israel has been giving up much
it gave up the Gaza it by the way
offered to give up the Gaza to Egypt way
back in the early 1980s he wouldn't take
it back there was no international
outcry over the occupation at the Gaza
by Egypt for 20 years no was there any
international luck and I'm sure there
must be a long record check Chomsky's
writing he must have in print large
opposition to the occupation of Gaza by
Egypt and strong opposition to the
occupation of the West Bank by Jordan
funny I never came across it in my
research but I'm sure it must be there
if you check at least the
Czechoslovakian version of one of his
writings and and so I I do think there's
a win-win solution the win-win solution
is the one I proposed starting in 1967
and that is Israel make territorial
adjustments necessary to secure its
boundary and Security's consistent with
Palestinian rights no occupation of
Palestinian cities a two-state solution
that is a win-win situation and and let
me tell you why I consider myself pro
palestinian I am pro-israel and pro
palestinian because i favor a viable
healthy economically strong politically
democratic palestinian state that will
be good for palestine it will be good
for israel it will be good for the world
israel has a major stake in the success
of palestine whereas the palestinians
have never had a major stake in the
success of israel and so i see a
successful palestinian state a viable
largely contiguous palestinian state as
a win-win situation not only for israel
of the palestinians but for the united
states and the rest of the world I only
hope that professor Chomsky can join me
in agreeing that we're not going to get
a perfect solution and let's just
advocate a solution that's acceptable
the question that was asked before was
to me the key question if the
Palestinians accept the solution that
Professor Chomsky finds
unacceptable will he use his enormous
resources as the most influential
intellectual in the world today to turn
the Palestinians against this peace
proposal or will he lend his great
prestige to urging the Palestinians and
his academic supporters all over the
world to accept a pragmatic compromise
solution professor Chomsky a lot turns
on you you are a very important and
influential person and therefore you
were to understand your power and use it
in the interests of peace just before
just before I asked one of the most
influential intellectuals today to
respond to Lori's question just to tell
you where we're headed professor Chomsky
will respond then in accordance with our
rules of procedure and decorum for this
evening I will ask professor Chomsky to
offer a two-minute summary for the
evening to be followed by professor
Dershowitz professor Chomsky well with
regard to my opposition to the jordanian
egyptian occupation there is ample
material in print and there has been for
35 years ever since i publicly and
openly and very prominently supported
the two-state settlement with mr. dosoo
it says he now supports I'm glad to hear
that evidence
let's return and that means of course
opposing jordanian egyptian occupation
let's turn to the question we were asked
to address where do we go from here
well we actually have two fundamental
choices one choice is to support
Washington's continued dedication to the
road the catastrophe that's outlined by
Israel's four former security chiefs
namely watching in silence
as Washington funds the canonization of
the West Bank the breaking of its
organic links to Jerusalem and the
disintegration of the remnants of
Palestinian society that choice adopt
the advice
moshe dayan to his cabinet colleagues in
the early seventies the hand was in
charge of the occupation he advised them
that we must tell the Palestinians that
we have no solution you shall continue
to live like dogs and whoever wishes may
leave that's the solution that is now
being implemented don't take my word for
it go check the sources I cited very
easy all English there's an alternative
the alternative to is to return to the
spirit of the one break in us Israeli
rejection ISM that is the week in Taba
in January 2001 before Israel called it
off and to take seriously the follow-up
proposals from high-level negotiators on
both sides of which the Geneva Accords
are the most detailed there is
overwhelming international support for
taking them as the basis for a political
settlement it does come close to the
long-standing international consensus
that the United States and Israel have
barred and that I've personally been
supporting for the last over 30 years
that's the road away from catastrophe
towards an end to violence and towards
eventual reconciliation either choice is
within our reach from that point on it's
up to us
professor Dershowitz we do seem to have
a remarkable point of agreement I think
we both do agree that the proposals made
at table do provide a useful basis for a
peace process now Taba didn't end
because Israel left Taba ended because
our fought rejected Camp David thereby
causing the election of Sharron over
Barak there was no government
essentially that could carry out the
table of proposals which were favored by
a very very large number of Israelis
that's why Prince Bandar are said to are
fought at Camp David and a table if you
reject the proposals at Camp David
you're gonna get sharone
instead of Barack you're never ever
gonna get a better deal thankfully he
was wrong
Sharon emerged as a man of courage and a
man of vision and I myself although I
never did support her own in the past
strongly support the efforts made by
Sharon in Paris a great great man of
peace a man who has vision a man who
imagines the future a man who can bring
about peace in the world and peace in
the Middle East and I think the
prospects for a peace based on the table
of proposals are quite realistic I think
that if this party wins the election and
invites the Palestinians to the table
and the Palestinians don't again miss an
opportunity to miss an opportunity there
will be a real prospect for negotiation
a real prospect for a peace based on
pragmatism one final word about the
sources please the other area where
professor Chomsky and I agree check his
sources take him at his word go back
tonight and Google and read the sources
read them in English read them and
whatever language you can and then email
us both as to what the sources show and
finally in a constructive and pause
way I urge you imagine peace imagine the
peace dividend that will come to the
world if finally a pragmatic solution
based on peace comes to the Palestinian
people and the Israeli people I'm hoping
for Shalom for Salaam and for peace
thank you thank you
just before we conclude and I thank our
speakers I want to share with you in a
very few seconds what I have heard
tonight standing between these two
scholars the first the first is that in
looking around this room it is clear to
me that being members of the
international community to which we all
belong whether we have been to Israel or
Palestine or to other conflict arenas or
not that people can care deeply about
people in conflict and understand that
there needs to be a way through secondly
as we heard from some of our questioners
the parties themselves Israelis and
Palestinians seem to be post
disengagement and in their to election
processes quickly approaching a
crossroads perhaps a tipping point where
some form of acceptable solution that
will involve some part of loss of the
dream to both sides will make pragmatism
rain
the third thing in which I've been
honored to be a part of this discussion
tonight is that a khadeem and the
scholarly community matter in this
discussion I have read a great deal of
the works of both professors Chomsky and
Dershowitz and in both of these readings
whether you agree with points of view
challenge their sources is beside the
point what you have been treated to
tonight is to individuals who have spent
a lifetime thinking
very very hard about some of the most
difficult problems in international
public policy and on behalf of this
group here tonight to my scholarly
colleagues I am eternally grateful thank
you for coming
alan dershowitz his book the case for
peace is published by Wiley Noam
Chomsky's latest is imperial ambitions
for more information visit american
empire project calm